past five months you have been waiting
for things to go back to the way things
work we fight the fire and rain shark
who does not swim droughts no move
forward you die I'm recruiting a new
team
the people that we are looking at has
some experience on the street you have a
farthest way to go I'm an Olympian takes
more than a few gold medals in a mask to
take on these streets oh they were
bronze
this
Green Arrow cannot be stopped unless we
all work together
[Applause]
what about Oliver Ollie can take care of
himself
hey youtubers is charlie so new arrow
SummerSlam season five trailer let's
break it down so a couple big new things
in this let's start with the Stardust
vml rematch so Cody Rhodes is guest
starring this season we finally see him
in a trailer he looks kind of zombified
like he's jacked up on mirakuru or
something in the hospital just laying
into Oliver so payback is a [ __ ] it's
gonna be a lot of fun to see them go up
against each other I don't think that
they've said which episode exactly he's
going to be in I think it's somewhere
towards the middle of the run the first
half of this season so maybe have to
like the first couple of episodes people
have been wondering if he is Solomon
Grundy I don't think that's the case
because I think that character is
supposed to appear on Gotham this season
so he could be a comic book character
but I think that they'll end it so that
he can come back in the future like they
won't kill him at the end of the episode
just think of it as like a SummerSlam
rematch the other thing we get in this
is a much better look at the new team
arrow and now they've kind of confirmed
it Ragman is going to be on the new team
a new rag man was going to be part of
the season but it didn't know that he
was going to be part of that starting
team so he's being played by this person
if you don't know who he is in the
comics I don't think they're gonna get
really crazy with his powers but the way
it works in the comics is is that he
where'd like the rags he's wearing are
the souls of the people that he's
defeated or the people that he carries
with him like the people that he's
trying to avenge he can use their
abilities so he can also use them to
absorb damage so he can summon a bunch
of different skills one at a time and he
can use them to soak damage but when he
defeats a villain he can absorb their
soul into the cloak so I don't think
they're gonna do that on the TV show
what they might have him do it just have
him take pieces of the clothing of the
people that he defeats and sew them into
his costume so instead of literally
absorbing their souls maybe he just
carries like a little piece of them with
him better look at wild dogs costume if
you haven't been reading Green Arrow
rebirth they actually just brought wild
dog back into the comics so he's going
on in rebirth right now while he's also
going out of the TV show but two
completely different storylines you
don't have to read green arrow rebirth
to understand what's going on in the TV
show right now but I almost forgot the
trailers really short so there might be
a little
usion with this person with the sword at
the end that's Prometheus the way to
tell him apart from Ragman because their
costumes bear some resemblance and the
way they wear a mask they look kind of
ratty like they've been patched together
prometheus does not have coattails and
rat wreck rag man is wearing a cloak
prometheus is wearing a jacket it's kind
of like a dark twist on the leather
costume that Oliver war for the first
couple of seasons so in that way
prometheus is going to be throwing a lot
of season one stuff that Oliver did into
his face as the vigilante like there
been a lot of theories about who
prometheus is but I feel like most of
those rely on flash point to explain
them like it's a resurrected Tommy yeah
it would be totally awesome if it was
Tommy some people are even wondering if
he's Connor Queen and it's like a retcon
from the Williams son for previous
seasons like Oliver has the lovechild
with this woman here so maybe flashpoint
mess with things and now his son comes
from the future Allah legends of
tomorrow to kill his father Oliver Queen
no I don't think that's what's going on
that would be pretty crazy but I'm
expecting prometheus to be someone who
is familiar but who was related to
someone that Oliver killed during season
one so we're talking like Edward Fyers
or like a really big character but
whoever he is I feel like it'll be an
aha moment like the light bulb will go
on and it'll all make sense like they've
been referencing season 1 over and over
and over so he's someone specific to
what happened during the first season in
the way they pitched the character is
that he's been training this whole time
since season one to defeat Oliver so
because we have Dolph Lundgren we make
all the rocky jokes you can think of him
as clubber Lang from rocky 3 so then we
go to mr. terrific they make a joke
about him being Olympic decathlete so
he's a bronze medalist he's like oh you
know I'm not a gold medalist I'm a
bronze medalist you see a scene here
where it looks like he tries to stand up
to some people that are trying to rob
him or something like that gets his ass
handed to him that might be part of the
reason why he goes to Oliver and says I
want to be on the new team arrow but
however many episodes they decide to
drag it out like it'll be an ongoing
thing him training the new team but the
first couple of episodes will be
hardcore training with him being like
the drill sergeant from full metal
jacket Stephen Amell said that after
they had started filming he's like oh
I'm having so much fun filming season 5
I have been more mean than I have been
in any previous season the other thing
is that Katie Cassidy was doing
conventions recently she said that she
would be in the first episode but it's
going to be flashback Laurel probably to
something from Season one just because
so much of the plot this season flows
from season one stuff so whatever is
happening with season one flashback
Laurel in that first episode it'll
provide context for the direction the
season is going so be sure to pay
attention to what's going on in those
flashbacks the flashbacks Oliver will
probably get his introduction to the
Bratva Russia is going to be where the
flashbacks are this season that's where
Dolph Lundgren will appear he'll be like
this big figure in the Russian brapa
that Oliver will have to go up against
so start logging away all your he-man
Rocky gifts I'm not exactly sure which
episode he's going to debut in it might
not be the first episode I think it's a
couple episodes deep but just for
reference they're filming episode 7
right now so they'll be filming the
mid-season crossover like the big four
night crossover episode for most of the
shows in another week or two so they
might start posting some teasers from
behind the scenes so you know whatever
ends up happening I'll totally do a
video for it but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner captain hot rocks
you win a gift card for the flash season
2 blu-ray be sure to private message be
on the back end of my channel so i can
get your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so they'll be more Marvel DC this
weekend ghost rider on agents of shield
is premiering next Tuesday Gotham season
3 premieres on Monday too so i'll be
posting videos for all that stuff while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about killer
frost on the flash season 3 and you can
click here to learn about the big
avengers easter egg they dropped on the
set of spider-man homecoming thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you